[inaudible]
in case you've been hiding under a rock or if you just don't have Twitter,
bless your heart.
Kanye West made is returned to the platform and proceeded to crack the Internet
with seven dirty words,
which would have put even George Carlin to shame.
Last Saturday,
Kanye tweeted,
I love the way Candace Owens thinks.
If you don't know Candice,
Oh,
and she's a black conservative woman who originally went under the youtube
moniker,
red pill,
black Candice caught fire online around the summer of 2017 and my interview with
her in which we discussed her evolution from a lefty to a conservative is one of
the moments that really put her on the map.
It was the first time that she had been able to explain herself in her own words
in a long form conversational setting.
I don't want to rehash the whole thing right now,
but Candace is no stranger to controversy and you may remember that infamous
debate that I had with Candice and Blair white late last year.
The whole thing was a debacle.
I make no bones about it,
but hashtag save Dave trended on Twitter.
So who am I to complain?
2018 has already been a huge year for Candice as she was hired as communications
director for turning point USA,
the largest conservative college group in America.
Since then,
she's been touring the country with Charlie Kirk,
talking to young people,
particularly young black people as why they should embrace the victor mentality
rather than the victim mentality.
This is included directly attacking the black lives matter movement as well as
democratic policies,
which Candace argues has decimated the black family and the black community.
Just last week hand is Charlie and I spoke at Berkeley to a wild crowd.
I'm proud to say that we had agreements and we had disagreements and even though
our styles are different,
no doubt,
Candice certainly goes for the jugular more than I do.
I always enjoy doing events with her and seeing her evolve politically.
Something I know a bit about myself.
She's learning as she goes and as she said to me in our interview,
if I had swallowed the red pill,
then she had snorted it.
Beyond any of the politics,
though,
Candice is a friend and our differences don't define us.
They actually bring us together.
All right.
Back to kindy for a second.
Beyond the headlines,
I don't know a ton about him,
although I'm obviously aware enough to recognize what a transcending cultural
figure he is.
Not only is he hugely successful in the music world,
he has a hugely successful fashion line and he's married to Kim Kardashian who
has her own empire.
You may not like the guy for whatever reason,
but make no mistake,
he is an absolute mogul.
I may not like or even respect the influence that celebrities have over culture
these days,
but Kanye is truly someone who can move people's minds with what he raps or with
what he tweets.
This is exactly what happened with these seven words.
Immediately after kinase tweet in support of canvas,
the Internet went ablaze Twitter moments.
Lead story was about Kanye support for far right.
Candice Owens.
Candace was called anti gay and racist.
Something I'm still confused about as she's had dinner here with me and my
husband at our home where her auntie game has never seemed to leak out as
racist.
There's nothing like a white lefty telling a black person who doesn't think as
they demand that they do,
that the black person is the actual racist against their own race.
Irony is truly dead.
Folks.
On Monday this week,
Kanye refused to back down despite hysterics from the media.
He tweeted out a bunch of videos by another former Rubin report,
guests,
bestselling author and dober creators,
Scott Adams.
In essence,
these videos were Scott talking about what a free thinker Kanye is.
That's it.
Next thing you know,
the usual suspects like buzzfeed media,
the daily beast and others were labeling Scott Adams as far right.
We've seen the script a million times before with anyone who dare challenge
leftist Orthodoxy,
be it Candace Scott,
column,
Moriarty,
Jordan Peterson,
or even little old me.
When mainstream media has moved so far left that this wide collection of people
are all smeared with the same charges of far right racism.
You know that the Overton window hasn't just shifted.
It's shattered.
The authors of these pieces aren't journalists.
They're activists,
or as Candice says,
they are a journalist there.
Hitmen to recap,
we have a new player in Kansas who is fearlessly saying how she believes that
the Democrats have used the black community for decades,
and that the victimhood mentality of the left is the root of this problem.
This,
by the way,
is similar to what plenty of other conservatives have been saying for years,
and yes,
this includes even black conservatives like my former guests,
Larry elder and Thomas Soul.
The voices of black conservatives and others espousing similar ideas has been
largely ignored by the mainstream media.
However,
and that is exactly why everyone is freaking out about kinase tweets.
He just gave oxygen to a set of ideas that the Democrats and the mainstream
media don't want you to hear,
and since they've controlled the narrative for so long,
they've relied on the usual smears of racism,
homophobia,
and bigotry instead of strengthening their own ideas.
Your ideas get fat and lazy when you don't have to work them out because you've
owned the narrative for so long.
This is where the modern left finds itself right now.
If canvas is views are far right,
then that means that about 40% of America,
if not more,
falls into that category.
I do want to address a different lurking danger here.
However,
I know Candace and I believe her to be forthright and passionate as she figures
this all out.
I obviously don't know Kanye nor any of his political beliefs,
so we've an interesting match here where Candace is now the rocket and Kanye is
the jet fuel.
If Candace doesn't do the intellectual work to really figure out what she
believes and why she believes it all the while being under the insane microscope
of the media that's going to be praying for her to fail,
well then the rocket will be faulty and this experiment will blow up.
What if Kanye says something absolutely crazy tomorrow,
which is not only possible,
it's probable or something that's counter to everything else that can believes
he's been known to stir the pot,
and I can only assume that something like that will happen either intentionally
or by mistake.
Does her rocket ship run out of fuel in mid flight?
Where does that leave this incredible momentum?
Over the past year when I've talked to people like Eric and Bret Weinstein,
Jordan Peterson,
Ben Shapiro,
Larry Elder,
Thomas Soul,
and many others.
What I'm most impressed by is how complete their outlook on politics and more
broadly on life is.
They don't jump from conclusion to conclusion.
Depending on the political climate.
They try to really understand what they fundamentally think,
so as new issues arise,
they're responses are complete rather than conflicted.
This is something I've really tried to incorporate into my thinking and
something that I know many of you are trying to do as well.
This will also be,
Candice is challenged now and I think she's up to it,
but only she can decide that for herself.
It blows my mind that every conversation we have in this room seems to become
more and more relevant as time goes by.
For All I know,
we'll have Kanye in that guest seat soon enough.
Whether he is just rocket fuel to boost ideas or is he the rocket ship that will
get us to the solutions remains to be seen but make no mistake.
The issues around free speech,
political correctness,
and the uncomfortable truths that might be the answers to those questions have
just been leveled up.
Are the players ready for the next level?
We'll soon find out.
Okay.